et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude mais
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors qu'elle est tout d'abord l'origine
de ce sommet pour bien qu'on comprenne
les choses se former un petit peu
insolite à cette remonte en fait au
monde d'avant c'est à dire avant la
pandémie avant la crise économique qui
s'en est suivie et aussi avant le
prendre dans le plan de relance de
l'union européenne il s'agissait pour la
grèce pour l'italie pour l'espagne
d'améliorer leurs mains dans les
discussions avec les pays du nord à
bruxelles puisque était axé d'appartenir
au club med aux pays méditerranéens avec
ce que cela implique et dans la dans la
désignation et que les pays du nord
était rigoureux sur le plan budgétaire
tout ceci a changé avec l'adoption lors
du dernier conseil européen d'un plan de
relance là tu fait que l'allemagne avait
dans le fond réalisé que son intérêt
bien compris et est de soutenir ce plan
de relance est de venir au secours les
pays du sud les plus impactés par la
crise
donc aujourd'hui à l'époque que bien sûr
la grèce il ya quatre ans avait invité
les six autres pays dont la france et
l'italie l'espagne et le portugal chypre
et malte et la france dont le fond
trouver un intérêt dans ce dans ce genre
de rencontre puisque elle appartenait à
la fois aux pays méditerranéens dont
elle pouvait être le leader et se faire
le porte parole auprès de l'allemagne
dont elle était le partenaire privilégié
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui le contexte est complètement
différent puisque comme vient de le
montrer votre sujet dont on ne peut pas
parler de méditerranée sans parler de
turquie et sans parler de sécurité
et effectivement ce sera probablement le
sujet de discussion majeur mais les
chefs d'état gouvernement parleront
aussi de migration parlerons aussi
d'économiser parleront aussi de sujets
d'intérêt commun
autre que la turquie justement cette
turquie que peut-on en attendre de ce
sommet par rapport aux cas turc
alors il s'agit comme il yal cela vient
d'être dit dans votre sujet de préparer
le conseil européen des 24 et 25
septembre qui à son menu les relations
entre l'union européenne et la turquie
la turquie n'est pas l'ennemie l'union
européenne d'ailleurs la turquie étant
en situation de l'union douanière avec
l'union européenne
il ya des accords très ancien de
l'accord économique très anciens entre
l'union européenne et la turquie
simplement évidemment le comportement de
la turquie fait que depuis un certain
temps les négociations d'une éventuelle
adhésion de la turquie sont gelés alors
je pense qu'en effet on confirmera ce
gel peut être même certains états
membres dont la france diront qu'au bout
du compte il faut être réaliste et que
la turquie n'a pas vocation à adhérer à
l'union européenne
même à long terme il se peut que demain
à ajaccio des pays comme l'italie comme
l'espagne refuse de le dire ouvertement
parce que l'italie et l'espagne ont
toujours été favorables à une grande
politique méditerranéenne de l'union
européenne et une grande politique
méditerranéenne de l'union européenne
ça comporte aussi la turquie est un
dialogue avec la turquie
donc il est tout à fait probable que
demain on insistera sur la nécessité
d'un dialogue entre la grèce et la
turquie
bien sûr les participants étant
solidaire des membres de l'union
européenne qui sont là c'est à dire
c'est à dire la grèce et chypre elle la
france elle en tout cas à déployer à des
navires de guerre et des avions de
combat dans la région pour soutenir la
grèce mais ce qu'elle est partie peu
isolé oui je crois que la position de la
france et qui est clair est là elle a
indiqué que que la position et les
différentes politiques poursuivis par la
turquie n'était pas acceptable et il ya
beaucoup de sujets y compris l'action
delà de la delà de la turquie en libye
vous savez qu'un navire français un
avenir mais un militaire français a été
sous le feu comme on dit d
radar tueur parce qu'il voulait
contrôler la cargaison d'un cargo turc
ce conformément d'ailleurs aux décisions
de l'onu
puisqu'il ya un embargo sur la livraison
d'armes et que tout le monde sait que la
turquie livre les armes au gouvernement
de tripoli les pro vraiment d'ailleurs
pas la seule puisque d'autres livrent
des armes au maréchal haftar toujours
est il que il ya eu cette rencontre
agressive entre deux navires de guerre
français et turcs et que depuis cette
époque en effet le président macron
demande que la turquie s'explique et
peut-être même que l'on décide de
sanctions à l'égard de la turquie
là-dessus l'union européenne est divisée
et cette division sera aussi refléter
demain au groupe des sept états
méditerranéens de l'union européenne
parce que encore une fois l'italie et
l'espagne considère que mieux vaut
dialoguer que d'imposer des sanctions
donc il est probable qu'on se retrouvera
avec ce débat en l'état au conseil
européen et l'otan dans tout ça le temps
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec la
réunion de demain puisque deux pays qui
participeront à la réunion en corse ne
sont pas membres de l'otan
chypre et malte ne sont pas membres de
l'otan alors malte parce que malte s'est
déclaré neutre et chypre parce que
d'abord c'est un état qui est dans une
situation particulière avec un conflit
que personne n'était capable de régler
depuis 1974 lorsque les militaires turcs
ont envahi le nord de l'île
beaucoup de tentatives ont été faites à
l'onu est ailleurs et ses tentatives ont
finalement échoué
le fait que le nord de l'île de chypre
soit occupé par un régime propres aux
turcs qui n'est reconnu par personne
soit par la turquie est d'ailleurs l'un
des problèmes parce qu'évidemment il a
une zone qui est sa mère territoriale il
a une zone économique et que dans cette
zone la turquie entend bien faire des
recherches pétrolières
or ce cette partie nord de chypre
ayant constitué un état que personne ne
reconnaît évidemment tout ce qui se
passe dans sa zone maritime est illégal
aux yeux du droit de la mer
suivant la convention de monterrey des
nations unies et puis ça n'est pas fini
parce que la turquie fait évidemment des
recherches pétrolières un peu partout
dans des zones qui sont contestées entre
la grèce et la turquie dont il faudrait
déterminer exactement la ligne de
partage des eaux la grèce et ailleurs
des îles très proche de la côte turque
évident considère que toute cette zone
maritime et sous sa juridiction
la turquie elle joue le jeu du plateau
continental ou de l'équidistance par
rapport au coût route est effectivement
on a un différend très important qui
demeure et qui s'aggrave et qui va
s'aggraver et puis il y aura ensuite un
autre sujet de conflit qui sera le
gazoduc venant d'israël passant par
chypre pour aller en grèce par
conséquent beaucoup de conflits au menu
des relations avec la turquie qu'il faut
essayer de déminer et pour le moment
l'otan n'y a pas réussi peut-être
l'union européenne
il réussira t-elle merci claude blanche
maison la question en tout cas restent
en suspens